I'm about to Freestyle wrap in this
sauna completely closed first suggestion
what would you like a rap about
distilleries distilleries greatest I
like it man after my own home
B2B selling the sickest wrap you've ever
seen yeah
hot tubs yes I love the imagination oh
whatever so um great okay yes
e-commerce e-commerce distilleries B2B
selling hot tubs can you tell we're at a
Tech conference
um and yes uh last one vegan carrots
vegan carrots that's what we're gonna
that's what we're gonna start nice
cool
it's a freestyle yes
the first word seeming so strange long
at the tip and the color all range I got
a story about the veg so I tell it I
unravel the story about the Cara ABI
needs in its vegan you know it can't be
beat doesn't contain the Animal product
there's no meat don't be scared why
because there's no Dairy it's the color
of white mixed with cherry yeah you like
to fade it down pick it from the ground
got a little bit of soil yeah I'm
looking all around kind of silly and
Distillery I'm making all the spirits if
I knock it down careful I never spill it
drink a lot one shot at a time I'm
waiting at the bar cut the front of the
line I say stop let me get all the
bottles I'm having such fun I'd want to
drink the bird Drive vodka gin and then
the rum but it'd be risky with the
whiskey I get it locally maybe get the
gym with the juniper berry and now oh we
free with no rehearse let me cash online
like the e-commerce on it
you know this some people were
struggling during colvid people online
much better than all the brick and
mortar the e-commerce story you know I
could have taught you all the facts and
put in all the paid ads I say hey look
on Facebook and take that I get the
click crew I wanna mix yours I mix
anything with no tracking pixels that's
the type that we do I'm there with my
Bros getting wild shirts off chilling in
the hot tub I've got some hot Honeys
there and I've got my drink probably a
Mojito and I think ah it's kind of
bubbly it feels Heaven Sent I'm enjoying
myself because I'm sitting on a vent
where the bubbles come true it tingles
it arouses if you're in a hot tub I
ain't wearing any trousers there's no
chance that I'm wearing out the pants B
to B I'm by the seat of my pants I'll be
taking all the glance and I'm gonna
impress I'm like Snoop Dogg Bizzle to
business yeah that's how you're doing it
you're working with the companies and
making any deal with investors right in
front of me I'm walking in it's not hard
to whip out my car to stay I sell stuff
from the back of my yard they like the
[__] a quick switch they say oh my God
we want you to come in you're a real
star and that's how I make that cash but
that's a lie only make the money there
when the freestyle oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
so enthusiastic